Luke Cage is more than a power-tool
exfoliating Jessica Jones love interest
he has a huge history of heroics and
interesting fashion choices also he's
getting his own show so before you watch
it find out who the heck is Luke Cage
he started out named Carl Lucas on the
rough streets of Harlem in the 1970s he
and his childhood friend will a striker
were criminals Stryker used knives but
Carl preferred his fists the two met
Riva Connors both fell for her but
Stryker ended up getting the girl the
two subsequently broke up because of a
really bad date Stryker blames Carl for
the break-up and flans heroin in his
house classic overreaction right Carl
goes to prison and doesn't make friends
with the inmates Riva dies in the car
wreck caused by Stryker
Carl doesn't make friends with the
guards Stryker adopts the name
Diamondback and now runs the town Carl
makes friends with dr. Noah Bernstein
who puts him in a biochemical electrical
bath made by Stark Industries and gives
him super-strength and vulnerable skin
and quick healing came out with
abilities Carl uses these powers to
escape prison once out he changes his
name to Luke Cage because he just got
out of one wanting revenge for Eva's
death Luke does the logical thing and
makes business cards for a Hero for Hire
and starts messing with Diamondbacks
business oh and he goes to a costume
shop and buys this sweet outfit Luke and
Stryker fight and Stryker blows himself
up with an exploding knife that was
meant for Luke Luke then goes into
business he rowing for money later Luke
starts going by Power Man because it's
more heroically marketable after a short
time Iron Fist joins Heroes for Hire and
the two go on to beat up dudes with
fantastic names like cockroach Hamilton
Cornell cottonmouth mr. fish and Freddie
fire face I'm just kidding about the
last one but the rest are totally real
for more on your favorite comics TV and
movies check out GameSpot universe